was LeBron's best troll moment wearing
this wrestling t-shirt after winning the
title in 2016. the Cavs had just beat
the Warriors to win the NBA Finals after
overcoming a 3-1 deficit coming off the
team plane LeBron was sporting an
Ultimate Warrior t-shirt while holding
the Larry O'Brien trophy social media
took off with the image accusing him of
hilariously trolling the Warriors by
calling himself The Ultimate Warrior
LeBron insisted it was not a slight but
merely a coincidence saying that his
wife Savannah bought the shirt she asked
me who my favorite wrestlers of all time
were and I told her sting Stone Cold
Steve Austin Ultimate Warrior The
Undertaker and Ric Flair as believable
as his story is we all know how
calculated LeBron can be after all he
was spotted the week before wearing an
Undertaker shirt at practice when it was
believed the Cavs were dead to the
Warriors much like the Undertaker the
Cavs resurrected and this was all
Illustrated through t-shirts this
incident sparked a t-shirt war between
LeBron and Draymond with Draymond
following up with a quickie t-shirt
after avenging their loss from the
previous year